welcome to this video playing Prince
panic from from the Netherlands and
let's do this one I can't forgot about
that he always plays this line we had
some sort of theoretical discussion here
and I'm remembering lately takes texty
595 this canned off position but here it
does not he does not seem to remember
exactly that's a good sign this is
international master billy Hendrix from
the Netherlands author of this
interesting book first think later very
catchy title I might screw up the screen
a bit yes sorry while he's thinking I'd
like to have this ad this window on
rapid it screwed up this window that
shows the statistics now on let's see I
have wow what is he doing you really
have completely forgot his theory here
or what exactly is happening one minute
for the capture I have three wins one
loss against him not bad at this what
does account I mean he's playing on the
ISC for ages this with this name yeah
that's that's new that's a new move
let's see ya what can I do
can i play f6 and e5 even just just very
directly on or maybe Bishop f5 yeah okay
let's do that I'm not not sure Queen 85
checky a specialty to this is not not
really doing much I'm just covering you
form yeah until 95 a thought and tending
93 I just can get really complicated
quickly let's see it's got 94 maybe hmm
care what now probably need to do that
it's not so easy now to play the pond
and sometimes you just play f6 andy sixx
but the knight on d4 of course is doing
a very good job in preventing them and
if i play if i play to the Queen
somewhere then Queenie for checkers
Andrea nuisance hmm hmm Queen if Queen a
552 Queen B 6
yeah it does not look too too great Jeff
yeah I don't know very very tricky on 24
checked I need to retreat oh it's not
yeah I've taken some liberties here
which probably get punished for now I
cannot go here let's create four at the
end I ce6 looks completely rotten
Queen eighth one check wow this looks
lost relief it looks like a lost
position I cannot do that oh yeah we
have decided to check afterwards I mean
I cannot believe that what he plate is
so brilliant and I'm losing immediately
but I do this is just terrible what the
heck was my mistake Bishop f5 maybe
maybe Bishop a five or so what's the
what's the reason this this looks like
where the Swiss cheese formation
unbelievably bad okay bishop where c 5
yeah it's just on d7 and i have no way
to protect that looks whoop dat this
Bishop Bishop f5 entirely entirely
ridiculous this position for black oh
wow Queen a sexy just takes and place 96
Wow
yeah I know Bishop f5 but maybe I can
sacrifice the Queen we should default
Bishop b6 and try to is not even going
for that I having this is also winning
Jim Quincy 7 ip54 mean you can only have
choose between different ways to lose
iam one minute ten everything winds
Quinby five yeah this is wrong not sure
that this was the best one even but it
is good enough probably not be five and
Bishop b5 yeah it's very easy to do it's
always really bad sign of the opponent
can cannot only win but can only win
really easily I know he can take in 96
but I had no move had no move I could
also resign you know taking 96 was very
shiny check
if I lose the deep on i will definitely
resign it's a okay it's not even a
slight hope but I'm a bit wandering a
bit about his long things because it's
so easy to play you can just take
everything was check and then when okay
here i can take be five it's a he's got
he's got an extra piece as well maybe
not even this as possible I was thinking
okay maybe here Bishop takes rook the
eighth Chuck what leg whoopee 7oz
checkmate and it's really so easy that
you can try a ton of really bad news and
still win time warner check check i'm
only continue because you missed so many
many simple wins that check check but
somehow feels like I should continue
check check check check okay okay okay
black ah ok took him ages to win this
this nonsense but I'm basically lost
here in the opening okay nighty too i
don't really believe this one bit but I
of course didn't didn't do anything
great against it the nola move causes D
5 D 595 Queen deform but that I really
must I must improve the end and do so
quickly this is maybe maybe even really
pisses bad already this weakness I
cannot go e 6f 6 yeah that's already bad
but what to do here it's not not easy I
can do something like f6 and e5 at least
start with this move this is better than
what I played but still not not so clear
what is my next move now it's not not a
parent I could I could go here pinning
this and increasing pressure on the
phone there are maybe this is the way to
go this this already looks nice yeah you
cannot prevent it actually so d5 is not
good yeah then this is the right move
Bishop g4
if you cannot play d5 what is this what
is he doing the computer wants to play
Queen c2 I wonder why i am not able to
just grab here okay he has got this or
even King takes the I'm too too far
behind in development okay but I don't
need to do that they can also just play
here maybe just go here it's not so easy
for him to take yeah this is simply
beyond repair i cannot i mean i must
must play maybe g6 or something this is
this is already already really bad I
cannot get my my king site developed
maybe 27 here so after that it's it's I
just I also didn't really appreciate
Bishop Bishop c3 yeah I'm busted really
you I can never play anything here f6
not possible e 6 mm cancel this song
disorders yeah this this is this is also
also very very bad as even this move
I'm completely toast the opening is
unplayable in that way absolutely
unplayable I must I must play I really
must play after 92 I must play this this
is this is okay i mean it's it's unclear
or whatever but what I played is simply
terrible yeah okay thanks for watching